hello everyone I'm Ilana welcome to my
channel what today I am showing you just
on 15 minutes of doom a tunnel gameplay
this is all on PC I can tell you that I
do have a copy of the final game right
now but that is still under embargo so
what I'm showing you right now is
actually gameplay from when I played
about three hours of the game back in
February
I like edited this up to show you like
specifically different things about the
game rather than just having a vehicle
combat real because those I have already
released so many of those so I kind of
wanted to talk about some of the changes
I think I can say that this game play of
seeing is very similar to the final game
but I'm still not a lot of actually
CAPTCHA be completed games gameplay so
this is doom a tunnel it is really
pretty this right here I wanted to start
off with because I feel like it's a
really good example of some of the set
pieces in the game there are just these
huge figures that have clearly been in
battle that you just kind of come across
in this game all the time it's just
there's so many pretty things in the
environment to look at it feels very
godly which I feel like is really
fitting oh this here is come on Alana
you'll figure it out
just those get me every time those
goddamn tentacles there are so many
points in this game play with my mouse
furiously shakes because I'm clearly
terrified of one of those they pop up
all the time a lot more environmental
hazards in Douma tunnel than doom 2016
was worth mentioning so yeah this is
Sentinel crystal this is one of the
level up systems you'll find them just
like kind of scattered across the world
and then I really wanted to start with
this particular chunk of combat because
another big thing about doom eternal
that I think really stands out to us is
doom 2016 is that it's very vertical and
you can see that on this we'll call it
math level very very very well the
amount of kind of T is that or amount of
platforms the amount of height like I'm
like I dropped that pretty
pretty soon it just means that you
approach the approach environments will
you eat differently and like obviously
that's an unintentional foal but then it
brings me the whole way up to the very
top so if I wanted to do that at any
point during a fight probably would have
if there are more enemies in this
particular environment I can do that and
I think that leans very well into the
amount of obviously weapon variety that
you have in doom I know some people
don't like it I was very satisfied with
its in new 2016 and it seems to have
gotten even a little bit more extensive
into maternal we just make a cut here to
check out these Cacodemons one thing you
want to notice about them is that I love
it so much
it's so good and then some of the
platforming yeah there is a dash boost
in the air to make sure that you
actually reach things and you have to I
believe its hold II that took me a
little while to wrap my head around I
kept falling even when I was pressing
that's because I wasn't holding it I'm
not a huge fan at the platforming but
you know did want to show you guys some
of it for the most part you know it's
okay it paces out the gameplay it makes
the game feel a little less stressful
but I think that I like doom for being
so high energy but yeah there's no there
is more platforming in this video in any
case so here we have a cutscene I don't
really feel like there are spoilers here
so no worries about that but if you do
want to skip ahead and skip ahead by
about 40 seconds it's so pretty though
there is a sentinel in this room big guy
piece that I wouldn't want to look at
also because I didn't mention it at the
start the embargo for this is next week
the review embargo is March 17 and the
streaming embargo is March 19 so a few
days for the game comes out so keep an
eye on that that's why I'm allowed to
tell you today that I had a code is
today we're allowed to talk about when
the review embargo is so you'll be
getting review embargoes so reviews draw
the next week and I'm gonna be streaming
twice next week for this one some
exciting stuff stay tuned for that
yeah look how cool that thing is they're
just everywhere
like I said it just looks like
somebody's frozen the mid-battle okay so
here we jump ahead to sort of the lost
combat segment of this particular level
she's breaking people's limbs off punch
them in the face
getting TAC and even shooting you in the
back yeah it's it's still very much like
an arena type of gameplay where you're
running around really really quickly
avoiding people in specific areas
you can't shoot the turrets off with
those guys I'm not sure if I did it it
wasn't always the easiest aim I'm
backtracking you know because I knew
that I had left some color of the back
there and this is like such a nightmare
to get here cuz the amount of
platforming that leads up to this pot in
particular I really didn't like just the
platforming in this one area drove me
nuts because it also has these like fire
traps like fire that prevents you from
being able to jump just evenly to a path
flat foam it's just it just seems like
an unnecessary thing to add to the game
but you know that's that's how I felt
based on this preview I can give you
guys full impressions of how I feel
about it
um next week and one I've actually
finished the game love using a chainsaw
get all that stuff back yeah for the
record I believe I was playing on hard
this portal shows up because I killed
everyone in the area but yeah I mean you
know Doom is a constant battle of
running out of ammo and running out of
health like that that hasn't changed by
any means I think this game is actually
harder than doing 2016 was for me so
here we have to jump to you're basically
home base I really want to do just like
walk around show you guys this a little
bit because I know people have been very
curious about this hub world you travel
to it and then you like leave it to get
to your next mission um I don't feel
like it was necessary but I do feel like
they'll probably end up doing some
interesting things with the story where
this is concerned this particular area
or the ship I feel like at some point
it's going to get invaded that almost
seems definite which will be cool it's
also yeah you're just running around in
this particular part basically powering
up the different areas of the ship you
different things you get new items here
will we'll see more of that but the
central batteries man gotta love those
so yeah we've just reestablished powered
core and supplementary systems which is
handy I guess I'm just gonna go get a
new weapon it's chillin over here
there's a nice grenade ice bomb there
you go yeah it's very cool so I mean the
weapon beretti's is really impressive
the fact that you have an ice bomb and
you also in doom eternal have your flame
belch which helps you get armor back
it's a lot of different stuff that
you're constantly like pulling out of
your inventory to throw at enemies and
and you know just constantly
replenishing your resources with all of
those different things and I find that
like management of that a lot of fun I
feel like at that part of why Doom
stands out against other first-person
shooters there's a lot of it is about
inventory management almost in a way
that's like as stressful as Resident
Evil sometimes but doom eternal also
yeah how's the platforming has a lot
more puzzles right here we're just
seeing suit upgrades I thought I just
keep this in so you guys can sort of get
an idea of what it looks like so yeah
you could stuff the traversal that
specifically and I think I upgraded that
which is monkey balls or whatever it is
that I upgraded because I'm so bad at
platforming it is like just the thing
that I'm the West and video games I talk
about this all the time completely fine
with every first-person shooter
component intentionally playing through
all of the original doom games on night
map right now but the platforming man it
kills me see like just immediately here
oh right off the ledge luckily didn't
die though but I didn't wanna show you
guys this area as well it's it doesn't
all look the same I feel like that's a
really important part of doom eternal
when I spoke to the development team
that's something that they said they
paid a lot of attention to was that doom
eternal even though it hides it very
very well sorry doom 2016 hides it very
well it frankly is a repetitive game
it's walk through a corridor and then
get into another arena and a lot of the
time they look very similar to every
arena
four hands just two different
environments so Duma tunnel has a bunch
more environments it has more
interesting things to do as you're
getting into those arenas because of
course they're still there and you know
the high energy combat is still an
absolutely massive part of this game for
sure I get yeah you're wrecked by him as
soon as he shows up love that love that
I think this is a you can see here you
shoot the turrets or rocket launches off
of their shoulders which wasn't that
easy to do with these guys because
they're actually pretty small and
obviously the revenue to move so much
that's kind of pain anyhow but I did get
this one yeah if she gotta love it makes
them just a lot easier to deal with in a
room full of people what's a strata like
to use to shoot someone a couple of
times with a rifle so you can eat them
and consume their health ok so again
we've just cut here jump forward a
little bit to a station area I think
we're gonna see a new enemy type here
not new to the series just new to do
maternal this is the part of the
campaign where it shows up get that
health pretty sure at least right after
we we grab this I guess like I told you
guys about the story stuff but I kind of
don't really want to
beautiful I really do like this area
it's really gothic covered in ice my
symbol is a minute as well some sort of
like spiritual stuff that I won't get
into I guess but um yeah yeah it
definitely feels like a slightly more
story focused version of doom 2016
they've made changes that do feel
important
yeah the the environment variety and the
things you do in between shooting bad
guys it's just a lot more to do they
took him out quickly I'm glad I hate him
jumpy boys just stay in one place it's
infuriating I'm using a plasma rifle a
lot usually I don't do that that much I
tend to change weapons a lot into very
is hey big guy
so as you can see you can shoot their
little arm cannons off which is really
cool and I found like on the manky
Busters I found it easier to do can't
stay still in Doom ladies and gentlemen
just because it's such a big target but
I like fighting math versus anyway like
I get happy when I see them them and
Cacodemons I'm like yeah it's gonna be a
good time there are some enemies that I
hate the pinkies fan in team 2016 I hate
them
whereas Wheatley an original doom I'm
like cool two shots with a shotgun I'll
take a pinky I don't care that's just
some where the game's evolved I guess
that was a cool platforming puzzle
thought I'd show that off that was an
issue I mentioned before where I die
either he'll de or only tapped it and
fell and it just like took my brain a
weird amount of time you get used to
because in virtually every other game
even if you're climbing and you only
have to like press one button you know
you have to press E even if you hold it
it won't drop you in Doom it does so you
know in Assassin's Creed you can tap a
to climb you only need to press it once
but you can hold it down it's not gonna
make you drop doom does make you drop so
it's just like a
a weird thing to wrap my brain around
that did catch me off guard a number of
times I love those those animations
that's so well done so brutal and the
sound design the music the score
incredible they get all our questions
when I announced they'd played it if
people asking me how I felt about the
store it's it's amazing like absolutely
no question there it's so so so good and
then this is a little platforming puzzle
here I just made a cut there so if that
looks like a loop that's why I think I
just had the game sitting for too long
and I didn't want you guys to book it
just I think I went to the bathroom
something out of it but yes this is a
little platforming puzzle they get way
more complicated than this there are
actual areas where I was like I don't
know what to do in this puzzle which I
don't feel like doing 2016 did it to me
maybe that one part with the BFG I was
like hmm whereas this has obviously got
to the little swingy monkey bars there
that I just didn't remember to look for
but again the verticality is a really
big thing you gotta look up and down
every which way to make sure you're
getting your Doom's done correctly in
this head do maternal which yeah for the
record I really loved this this preview
build I had a really good time playing
it I have some impressions as a QA but
you guys should just wait for next week
we're gonna have plenty more doom
I love doom you love doom thank you for
to Bethesda for letting me get to play
this at the preview event and yep still
cannot talk about the complete game just
yet I have made sure not to do that in
this video I'm pretending that I have
not played the new version of the game
just showing you the old stuff and
that's it for me everyone I hope you
enjoy let me know if you have any
questions I will answer whatever I can
without breaking embargo I'll see you
guys next time